I'll try and give you as the name
suggests a proper introduction to this
topic because I said we were going to
start on Monday and you did started on
Monday but you had to do without the
benefit of any explanation so I'm going
to try and I'm doing a little better for
you today all right
so um to begin with I want to try and
get in your head why are we doing this
topic communications systems um you've
been looking at communication systems
for a long time haven't you
like you know virtually every system
you've been thinking about it seems has
been a system that that has
communication in it right so why are we
looking at this well I want to
distinguish between three different
categories of system okay I've got them
here in the first task information
systems systems that communicate and
communication systems they might seem
very similar to you and admittedly they
do overlap quite significantly as you'll
see in a second I would try and
distinguish between them okay so I was
trying to think about a Venn diagram
that would that would represent these
and usually we think of Venn diagrams as
these things
you got like these overlapping
interlocking circles and sometimes this
works right you know students who take
commerce and students should take IPT
right there's some we take only one some
we take only the other and some you take
both and then there's ones who take
neither right when it comes to these
three categories these ones that I'm
showing you here they don't quite
overlap in the traditional Venn diagram
way this is this is still a Venn diagram
by the way it's just a different kind
okay so let's start from the top the
most general term what the one you're
most familiar with information systems
information systems it's the broadest
term that's why it's on the biggest I
was going to call it a circle but I
don't really know what shape it is the
biggest area okay
information systems you know what they
are collection of interrelated parts
that work together to achieve a common
purpose specifically to do it processing
information you guys are very familiar
with that
okay now I wanted to draw out what this
is as distinct from the next level in or
the next more narrow set which is
systems that communicate
now let's just before we go any further
can you see right that there are systems
which are information systems but they
don't communicate okay we don't tend to
think about them because they're not as
fancy or cool or modern but they're
everywhere around us for instance they
might be on your wrist okay so this is
why I had to ask for one of these
because I'm well I have one but it's
analog and we're trying to think of
electronic ones so anyway this is an
information system yes who agree what's
its purpose to tell the time thank you
and it's got cool other functions as
well where I can tell you today you can
allow you to on time a specific small
period because it's going to stop
watching it won't you come in it's an
information system there's no two ways
about it
right but this system cannot communicate
with any other system right it's a if
you like it's a closed system right so
it's an information system at a can't
communicate so a watch would be out here
there's my pathetic attempt at drawing a
wristwatch okay now before we go on I'd
like you to think of some other examples
as well here's one okay I'm going to
give you examples each way along each
level along the way but I'd like you to
think of a few more okay so here's an
information system but it can't
communicate now systems that communicate
we're really thinking about systems that
communicate with other systems right now
to draw out what these are let me
distinguish between this and the next
level which is what the one we're really
interested in well whatever my colors
change yep that's better
nestled right in the middle the most
specific home are what I'm calling
communication systems okay
and once it is through these guys and
the next level are okay systems that
communicate their systems that
communicate with other systems but their
purpose doesn't really have to do with
communication okay
their purpose remember what a purpose is
very important okay my example for you
is a traffic light what is the purpose
of a traffic light driving on the road
and you see a traffic light up in the
you know hanging off a pole what's its
purpose seeing it why is it that the
tell you when to go when to stop when to
slow down okay so that's a very that's a
very user centric sort of way of
describing its purpose you may also say
its purpose is to ensure the flow of
traffic right in a safe and orderly way
does that make sense that you agree with
that purpose okay now can you see that
the purpose of this system doesn't have
to do with communication explicitly
right does that make sense
if this traffic light could accomplish
that purpose accomplishing you know safe
and orderly traffic right without
communicating then that would be fine it
would still be serving its purpose right
but as it is at least the current
design traffic lights the traffic light
can't do that purpose it can't
accomplish it without communicating
whose have to communicate with hmm think
think think I'm talking specifically
about other systems what are this
because that's what communication
transmitting receiving is right I which
other systems is the traffic light
communicating are good the you know that
that button that we press when we want
to cross the road right it's a little
system in itself and I don't know if
you've ever been walking along the road
but sometimes you'll see like a big
green box it's about it's about as tall
as me right as rectangular and it says
you know a black and yellow number on it
it says don't touch because electrical
stuff excited there's a computer system
in there that receives input from those
pedestrian buttons right and then it
communicates the traffic lights and
tells it hey you should go red now
yellow down whatever so this system is
communicating okay so let me draw a
traffic light okay it's communicating
but it's only communicating because it
has to right if it could do its purpose
some other way that'd be great and we
would do it okay
so again it's really to do with purpose
okay the system communicates but
communication is not at the core of why
it exists right so now you can really
get up what's a communications system as
distinct from a system that just
communicates okay I'm a communication
system is an information system which
communicates but it's its purpose has to
do with communication right the reason
it exists is to communicate with other
systems alright and so the most common
example of this I gave you a couple of
days ago it's one of these right now
just think about this right this is a
system that communicates but it's more
than a system that can eat it if this
system can't communicate it doesn't have
a purpose does that make sense it's
different to the traffic light right the
point of this system its purpose is to
transmit a message to be received by
someone else and to receive a map okay
so this is a communication system your
modem at home the phone in your pocket
in some ways in some ways your laptops
they are communication systems right TV
towers radio stations they are
communications they can't communicate
their purpose doesn't make sense okay
okay so that's distinguishing between
these three different categories I'd
like you to think of more than just the
three examples I gave you okay how do I
draw a phone okay
phones are really easy to draw these
days because I just have to draw that
oh look it's an iPhone okay um so
there's one example for each I'd like
you to think of two more for each so
that you'll have three in total okay
just so that when you come back to this
view you'll remember and understand what
these different categories are